Shure: 起床了蜜娜桑
Shure: Time to wake up, everyone.
Shure: 起床啦
Shure: Wake up!
Shure: 是不是又睡过了
Shure: Did you oversleep again?
Shure: 起床啦路亚
Shure: Wake up, Luyah.
Shure: 起床啦
Shure: Wake up!
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 谁呀
Shure: Who's there?
Shure: 说早上起来一起收拾收拾收拾院子的
Shure: Who said they'd help clean the yard this morning?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Huh?
Shure: 等你收拾完黄花菜都凉了
Shure: By the time you're done, the flowers will have wilted.
Shure: 大家都饿死了
Shure: Everyone will starve.
Shure: 你看就你起床了
Shure: Look, you're the only one up.
Shure: 就你按时起床了
Shure: You're the only one who got up on time.
Alice: ：就我按时起床了对
Alice: I'm the only one who got up on time, right.
Shure: 管管你这两个室友啊
Shure: Take care of your two roommates.
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Shure: 管管你这两个室友
Shure: Take care of your roommates.
Alice:他们俩都还没起
Alice: They're still not up yet?
Shure: 没起
Shure: Not up.
Alice:好他们比我还厉
Alice: Wow, they're worse than me.
Jake: 哎您您到您您您到53再给我打电话吧
Jake: Hey, call me when you get to 53.
Shure: 害
Shure: Ugh.
Jake: 要不行吧
Jake: Or maybe that's not right.
Jake: 哎御河区53号别人都能找着
Jake: Hey, everyone can find No. 53 in Yuhe District.
Alice: 露西啊对你该戴眼镜
Alice: Lucia, you should wear glasses.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Jake: 挨着挨着挨着
Jake: Right next to it.
Jake: 对您您找53号
Jake: Yeah, find No. 53.
Jake: 53号好找
Jake: No. 53 is easy to find.
Shure: 煮几个白水蛋吃你吃吗
Alice: 有鸡蛋啊
Alice: Do we have eggs?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Yeah.
Alice: 你要煮几个
Alice: How many are you going to cook?
Shure: 不知道多少个人吃
Shure: I don't know how many people will eat.
Shure: 随便煮点
Shure: Just cook some.
Shure: 然后一会再煎点
Shure: Then we can fry some later.
Shure: 拿6个吧先
Shure: Take 6 for now.
Alice: 现在几个
Alice: How many now?
Shure: 现在5个
Shure: Now we have 5.
Shure: 再拿一个
Shure: Grab another one.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Alice: 水太多了是吗
Alice: Is there too much water?
Alice: 嗯无所谓就这样吧
Alice: Hmm, never mind, let's just go with it.
Shure: 差不多
Shure: It's about right.
Alice: 没有锅盖好像
Alice: There's no lid for the pot, it seems.
Shure: what
Shure: What?
Shure: 有有吧
Shure: There should be, right?
Shure: 这个能盖上它不
Shure: Can this cover it?
Alice: 这个好脏
Alice: This is so dirty.
Jake: 成果如何
Jake: How's it going?
Shure: 叫醒了
Shure: Woke it up.
Shure: 哦我还没
Shure: Oh, I haven't yet.
Shure: 我还没洗漱
Shure: I haven't washed up yet.
Shure: 我想起来
Shure: I just remembered.
Shure: 那还有个煎锅吧
Shure: There's also a frying pan, right?
Alice: 现在就煎吗
Alice: Are we frying it now?
Shure: 我先刷刷吧
Shure: Let me clean it first.
Shure: 还可以
Shure: It's still okay.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice: 你会煎吗
Alice: Can you fry it?
Shure: 放心
Shure: Don't worry.
Shure: 长这么大还没饿死呢
Shure: I've grown this big and haven't starved yet.
Shure: 绝对稳稳拿下好吧
Shure: I'll definitely handle it well, okay?
Shure: 把火烧一下就好
Shure: Just turn on the heat.
Shure: all
Shure: All set.
Alice: 你要几个蛋
Alice: How many eggs do you want?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Huh?
Shure: 咱们昨天是不是买那个面包来着
Shure: Didn't we buy bread yesterday?
Shure: 把那面包然后裹点蛋液煎了吧
Shure: Let's coat the bread with some egg and fry it.
Alice: 面包在这吗
Alice: Is the bread here?
Alice: 不在吧
Alice: I don't think so.
Shure: 昨天说烤结果没烤是吧
Shure: We said we would toast it yesterday but didn't, right?
Shure: 这里是什么呀
Alice: 红薯
Alice: Sweet potato.
Shure: 这要不也加上得了
Shure: Why not add this too?
Alice: 面包应该在上面
Alice: The bread should be on top.
Shure: 是吗好
Shure: Really? Okay.
Shure: 有人回想问一下具体时间
Shure: Can someone ask about the exact time?
Shure: 因为我们可能也会有演出在5月底
Shure: Because we might have a performance at the end of May.
Shure: 就是怕有撞车
Shure: Just afraid of a car crash.
Shure: 哎面包是在楼上吗
Shure: Hey, is the bread upstairs?
Shure: 啊哎哎我记得不是买了两袋面包吗
Shure: Ah, hey, didn't we buy two bags of bread?
Jake: 是啊
Jake: Yeah.
Shure: 怎么剩一袋了呢
Shure: Why is there only one bag left?
Shure: 你昨天晚上偷偷吃了
Shure: Did you secretly eat it last night?
Shure: 我的
Shure: 真没吃呢
Shure: I really didn't eat it.
Lucia: 楼下我昨天那个
Lucia: Downstairs, I...
Lucia: 昨天昨天放那个蛋清空间不够
Lucia: Yesterday, I put the egg whites, not enough space.
Shure: 啊啊
Shure: Ah, ah.
Shure: 还有个在楼下
Shure: 还有一袋在楼下他说
Shure: There's another bag downstairs, he said.
Shure: 他说有一
Shure: He said there is a...
Shure: 袋在楼下
Shure: Bag downstairs.
Shure: 没看着
Shure: Didn't see it.
Alice: 啥
Alice: What?
Shure: 楼下你看到那有那什么的吗
Shure: Did you see anything downstairs?
Alice: 啥呀
Alice: What?
Shure: 有那个面包
Shure: Any bread.
Alice: 嗯没有吧
Alice: Hmm, I don't think so.
Shure: 谁知道
Shure: Who knows.